What is my advice to young men looking for a wife to marry and start a family with?
Yes, okay. A clear question.
What you cannot ignore is the requirement of mutual attraction.
This is important. And mysterious.
So for example, this is something crazy.
One of the things we know that attracts people to each other is a symmetrical face.
You can give men a rating for the degree of symmetry of their face.
Then you give the most and the least symmetrical men a clean t-shirt to wear for a day.
Then let your women judge the smell of the shirt on attractiveness.
The women will find the smell of the symmetrical men more attractive.
And there are more factors that determine sexual attraction that are based on biological factors.
They are deeply embedded in our nature, such as scent.
Women also appear to be less attracted to the smell of men with a rhesus factor that can cause problems when having children.
One reason women give for finding the smell of such men unattractive is that they smell too much like their brother.
Strange, mysterious things determine whether or not people are sexually and physically attracted to each other.
I think this is an important part of a marriage relationship.
Almost as important is trust, man, there is no successful marriage without trust.
You must be honest with each other.
One of the reasons Carl Jung believed that marriage should be an oath and a covenant was very wise.
You know, being honest with someone is not easy, because there are many things about us all that are terrible, weak, repulsive and shameful.
And these things must come to the table and be discussed.
But you are not going to tell the truth about yourself to someone who can scream away when you reveal who you really are.
So the marriage bond is something like: Ok, here's the deal. I chain myself to you and you to me.
And then we tell each other the truth and neither of us can run away.
And when we know everything, then we are going to torture each other with it or we will try to face that truth and try to become better people.
Together. And thus we become more powerful and resilient and deeper and wiser as we go through life together.
I think that's brilliant. Because if you leave a way open, man, then you will use it, that's for sure.
The oath is there - and this was Jung's vision of the spiritualization of the human couple band.
By a Christian marriage, for example, that emphasized the, let's say, subjection of both participants to a higher power as embodied in the Logos.
So the idea is that in a Christian marriage, for example, not the man or the woman is the boss, but the shared person who is seeking the truth in both of them.
You can see this as their joint submission to the Logos.
And that's so true, man.
The benchmark for your married life should be your promise to tell each other the truth.
Because at a difficult moment in your life, if you have done something incredibly stupid that can cost you the head, if there is no one you can turn to ...
If you have a partner that you can trust, you can say: Hey, I made a big mistake with money, I am awake, I feel so stupid and it can go completely wrong.
This person will help you come up with a solution.
And he or she will know that when it is the other way around - and that will certainly happen - you will be there to talk to you, and that you will work it out together.
This is important.
There are a few things in our culture that are completely wrong, and one of them is the underestimation of marriage. That's a bad idea.
Your marriage is one third of your life, maybe more. And children, also one third.
The rest out there is also one third of the life, just about.
To miss anything is a huge mistake.
That being said, there are also people who have to miss one or more because they have a good reason for it.
Perhaps they are incredibly creative artists who have to devote themselves entirely to their career.
Or they excel in one way or another and can justify thereby sacrificing part of the life trinity for another part.
But in general that is very dangerous, and you shouldn't do it.
Children also have a bad time, while they can be great fun if they behave well.
One of the chapters of my new book is called "Don't let your children do anything that you don't like them anymore."
This is possible, especially if you discuss it well with your partner, with the person who helps you raise your children.
And children are the best company, because they are very enthusiastic about everything. They love new things.
They love you, so they are happy when you get there.
You just have to make sure that they are not too hot or too cold, and that they have eaten and are not too tired.
And don't expect them to keep their attention for longer than they can.
We took our children out to dinner when they were little, and they sat at the table without any problems when they were two and three years old and behaved well.
But no longer than 45 minutes.
You shouldn't ask too much. But I have noticed that small children become restless and unreasonable about five to ten minutes earlier than adults.
Only they are too stupid to notice. Children notice it immediately.
OK, back to the marriage.
You are looking for someone who you find attractive, who you love and who you trust in damn well.
And then you are honest with them.
And so you may be able to beat yourself through life, and find someone with whom you can intertwine the rope of your being into a stronger rope of yours together.
So that your story gets some continuity, and you can have children and then grandchildren.
And then you have a life, man.
It's such a privilege if you get that done, so that's it.
My answer to the question: What is your advice to young men looking for a wife to marry and have children? OK then.
And furthermore, marry someone you think she would be a good mother to, and who is so wise to know that she also wants children.
Some women do not want children. Fine. And some women might not get them. That is also possible.
But the rule of thumb is that a woman in her mid-20s who doesn't know - or doesn't want to admit - that she wants children, unless she has a burning reason for it,
psychologically speaking, she has not listed them.
She does not know what is important in life.
That can of course also apply to you. That is probably also the case.
But it's a good rule of thumb.